hey guys it's me I just seen yeah you
might be wondering why I look like a
passion fruit well maybe it's because I
am a passion fruit I was so excited
because I made a cameo in Annoying
Orange video which I'll annotate and I
guess I can't point to it because uh as
you can see I don't really have any arms
speaking of not having any arms do you
know how impossible it is to edit video
without any arms good thing for a
trackpad because I just roll around on
that thing and welding stuff on the
screen happens whoo good thing for that
and you know what another thing while
I'm ranting here hmm all these are the
fruits they keep trying to hit on me and
people be squeezing me ice cube oh oh
come on baby I think you're adorable
really you think yeah you're hot stuff
thank you it's nice to get a compliment
from someone that isn't a fruit hey I am
a fruit